do you think we can wait I don't I think  now is the time to fight climate change  right now is the time to put pressure on  our governments make them come up with  radical laws for radical changes changes  that will make the major companies join  this battle because we need them we need  them to come up with new ideas how to  save the climate save the place we live  in  you know we chose our politicians so  let's tell them what should be done I  think now is it's time to fight climate  change right no governments need to act  before it's too late  so leave a message on www.vitac.com  additions to wake up I'll be posting a  message as well fight climate change